hey this is Jason with the local
locksmith company today we're making a
key for a
2019 Chrysler Pacifica here it is right
here it's just add a key we're just
adding a key to it anyways
uh I got Justin helping me today so
here's how you do it so
see we're going to use the 128 cable
where's the cable we going use this 128
cable we got it connected to our OBD
connector Port from our for our Al
and we're using uh we're going to remove
this panel right here to do
that to do that I have this tool right
here it says a door unlock tool but it's
a good for plastic it's a plastic tool
for getting trim pieces off so I'm going
to pop it off and try to hold the camera
and do it at the same time stick it
under
here and just pop it like
that just like that so that comes off
okay and then underneath of here now I
don't know if you can see it but there's
the modules right there see the little
paper with the wiring and all that
there's wires on this end we're going to
pull the two wires off that end I'm
going to put you on a hold till I get
the wires off cuz I can't hold the
camera and do it at the same time all
right Justin has the 128 cables right
here and then the plugs are right in
here he's going to plug those two
together and we're going to start to
program it so go ahead and plug them in
Justin
Justin's a trainee so he's learning how
to do these it only going in one
way this that's the big one on the left
there you go
all right he's got
one so he got them both hooked all right
so now we're going to start put the car
in hit the start button on the
car all
right we're going to put this original
remote back here so it doesn't get
affected by the
new the new one doesn't get affected by
it all right so we're going to go into
hit
immobilizer
accept and then you're going to hit that
blue button up at the Top Auto
detect and then you're going to go into
it's going to tell you what you have to
do you don't have to read
it all right
Chrysler it's going to pull the V
then all right what does it say if you
have a learned key and to execute
automatic selection please select the
correct brand vehicle if it is a
pre-2006 okay just hit
okay establish and vehicle
connection let's make sure we have
a hot spot going our hot spots
going okay this is a smart
key so you hit smart key 2019 Pacifica
smart key
okay okay we want to hit um control
unit uh read the passw immobilizer
password okay what's it say turn the
ignition off and turn the hazards on off
[Music]
no they're on
here see right
there
perfect hit
okay okay oh it might be cuz it's time
run though turn it turn it
[Music]
off yeah H it off okay that's what it
was no read password yep good job
hazards
on takes 1 to 10 minutes it should be
pretty
quick all right let's see what it's
doing all right we're going to pause
until it reads it all right it's pulled
the password the password is
36745 hit okay 36745 remember that
immobilizer
yep so we're going to key
learning number of
keys there's
two key
learning
okay please make sure that the ignition
is off and all wireless devices and cell
phones and other things are out of the
vehicle current key would you like do
you want to learn the key
yes it's establishing the connection
okay it automatically loads the pin okay
where's the new key the new key is right
here in this bag
okay here's the new key it doesn't work
right now see it's no nothing's working
okay go ahead hit
okay establishing
vehicle hold the proximity button by the
stop start button and complete the
procedure within so many seconds
continuously PR
release until here the door's
unlock all right hold this camera there
it goes hear it all right so this one's
done okay the current number Keys is
three hit um do you want to learn the
next one no we're done uh so we're done
so just exit out
Escape All right so now we got to put
all this stuff back together we'll put
all this stuff back together that's
pretty quick and easy this is an
aftermarket customer supplied
aftermarket smart
key hit the brake and the we'll start it
hit the
brake starts right
up oh this has been Jason with the local
lock it's been Jason with the local
locksmith company just 2019
Chrysler Pacifica smart key we did the
128 cable system there's other ways to
program these but we did the 128 um if
you like the video hit like if you want
to see more hit subscribe thanks for
watching and visit our website at myw
locks.com thanks